but now let's get into that big story
it's from the daily mail
american truckers join canada's freedom
convoy protesting vaccine mandate as
rigs stretch for 45 miles trudeau plays
it down and calls protesters a small
fringe minority look at this
with 50 000 truckers driving from
vancouver the freedom convoy 2022 is
demanding that their government abolish
vaccine passports
they say as many as 32 000 or about 20
of truckers are not vaccinated now
there's so much craziness to this story
aside from the fact this line is massive
gofundme what do they raise like five
million dollars already is that it well
that's what i heard yesterday that they
had canceled a five million dollar froze
it froze yeah i think they released it
oh this is big it's it's amazing because
we had that big dc protest you know this
past weekend uh robert malone when joe
rogan's podcast had mentioned we're
gonna go to dc in protest wasn't that
big
was not that big i think luke was down
there and he said maybe 10 20 000 people
and i was like well you know but now
we're getting 50 000 truckers stretching
45 to 50 miles it looks like gofundme is
releasing 1 million of the 5 million for
some reason not all five million i don't
i i can't um understand why they would
even use gofundme yeah no i don't know
why you would at this point it's
interesting because this article that we
were all looking at points out that the
longest convoy prior to that was five
miles long
yes and you have justin trudeau saying
this is a small fringe protest because
this is what they do anytime they want
to turn public perception against the
popular movement they either claim it's
not large or they ignore it they do it
at the march for life every single year
which is part of why i went there this
year to cover it because there were tens
of thousands of people there but they
always make it sound like it's a no-show
event how many people do you think were
down there at the
i couldn't estimate but it was tens of
thousands definitely well and it wasn't
just in dc too it's happening all over
the country yeah very true yeah capitals
virtual life is national yeah oh yeah
yeah
well vaccine passports
this is i've been waiting for the united
states for americans and canadians to
unify in some way against against
government overreach just americans and
other and other
you know people from around the world
australia
what is this going to mean for our food
and stuff you know because are these
guys effectively not working by doing
this there's already a trucker shortage
yeah exactly i mean i was sort of
talking about this yesterday but the
idea that we could afford to lose 20 of
our truckers across any border if the
economy was doing well would be
ludicrous
with things as bad as they are it's
insane to even
have justin trudeau or any civil
authority ignore this pretend as if it's
not a big deal and try to force their
demands on the truckers he either
doesn't realize the leverage that they
have or more likely he realizes they do
have leverage but he doesn't care
because he's not going to get hurt when
the shelves aren't stocked you are
what i don't get is why are they
targeting truckers specifically because
most of your time you're alone in your
cabin
you're not i mean and so and okay maybe
you're at the flying j to pick up some
snacks
why not the motorist in the car the
four-wheelers you know agreed like
well
why truckers
for whom we rely on i don't understand
that and then i don't understand omicron
i think changed the calculus for
everything like you know it's just
breakthrough cases are everywhere so
whether you are vaccinated or not at
this point it is irrelevant to whether
you will get omicron if you look at all
of this through the lens of public
health you will be confused the whole
time exactly if you look at this through
the lens of someone trying to destroy
economies
everything makes sense exactly why would
cuomo willfully kill people
andrew cuomo in new york was like i'm
going to put sick people in nursing
homes and they'll die and he was warned
that would happen now why would he do
that if he was trying to save lives that
literally makes no sense the problem
because he got a lot of money from the
hospital associations
to campaign donations to his campaign
yeah but because they were pressuring
him because they wanted the money right
no we put them in nursing homes well
they're nursing well the administrators
of both the hospitals and the nursing
homes the nursing homes said give us
sick people they wanted the money
is that is that it
was killing all these people yeah
he wanted the campaign he was under
their pressure the nursing home said
give us more people to make us money
that's that as i understand it that's
what they want they wanted the people
there well then it killed people for
money well also i think a lot of this
makes more sense if you look at it
through the lens of
these people being control freaks who
demand our compliance so you asked why
go after truckers i think part of the
reason is because they just need to see
people bend the knee i think that's a
huge reason why these mandates are being
pushed on people they don't want you
making your own medical decisions they
want to make those decisions for you i
believe that and i think they view it as
a challenge
well i think they view it as a challenge
to their authority if people don't take
their recommendations and do the things
they told them to do and they don't care
who has to get suffered who has to
suffer when those people are punished
that's what i believe it's too
simplistic i don't think so i think that
they i think that these people are
control freaks yeah but control freaks
that want something like the idea that
they're just like you know what we have
no reason to do this but we'll do it
anyway no no all right so here's the
thing i absolutely believe that there
are probably other motives there but i
think once people start standing up and
saying no then the new motivation
becomes well i need to make sure that
they fall in line because if they can
say no to this they can say no to the
other demands i make on them
i think
a lot of this is political i think
there's political strategy behind it
definitely i think they uh you know the
interesting thing is that it spans all
these different countries
you've got europe enacting much of the
same policies that we enact here that
you know canada is doing now interesting
interestingly we're seeing in europe a
bunch of these countries start to end
their their their lockdowns like denmark
i think the netherlands um a few others
while some are getting even more strict
i don't i i i look at this to the lens
of a pandemic none of it makes sense
it's like you're trying to put a puzzle
together but if you've got the wrong
picture it's the pieces won't go
together
and if we look at look at this through
the lens of coordinated political
manipulation then it all makes sense
it does why go after truckers they're
destroying the economy
why destroy the economy i mean i don't
know man there's a there's a bunch of
different reasons for one look at what
bill de blasio said that he wants to buy
up the buildings in new york city now
that they're worthless because people
are fleeing and turn them into public
housing so there's one good reason to do
it yeah you go after the truckers you
depress wages you smash small businesses
you transfer wealth back up to the
elites the elites who call themselves
the elites in the world economic forum i
mean that
looks you know plain and simple now i
suppose if you want to take it one extra
layer deep we can you know listen alex
jones talking about an alien
intelligence taken over but that one's a
little too far from that i can't go
there yeah global elites who are trying
to steal money from the working class
well that's history
well yeah that's that's socialism that's
marxism that's the one that's human
nature to grasp more power that's just
ad infinitum that's how humans have
always been um and we're we see this in
real time right now in central america
um it's just heartbreaking to see that
a strong man strong woman whatever
dictator they don't care about the
people it's all about in cuba same thing
that that's how it is if you want if you
get power you're power hungry your power
drunk uh unless you believe that the
power rests with the people then
fundamentally if you if you
fundamentally don't believe that the
power rests with the people and that you
are better than them then you're going
to keep stealing more power that's just
human nature what i find funny about
this is the the the posts and stories
where it's like it's white supremacists
you know like that that's their go-to
for everything yeah aliens if that well
as if that's in any way an explanatory
narrative here like why don't these
people want to get this injection oh
they must hate black people what are you
talking about a bunch of racists got in
their trucks yeah
it makes no sense but well not to
mention the vaccine hesitancy among
black americans is i think in many cases
a lot higher than white especially
but
because they're trying to scare black
people to not get it they're doing the
same thing right now with a march uh uh
march for life yeah of course the the
patriot front group
that no sane person thinks is an actual
group i know it was apparently at the
march for life and now all these
articles pop up where they're like why
white supremacists like the pro-life
movement or whatever and i'm like i
don't understand why they would that
makes no sense yeah that's absolutely
insane what about margaret sanger she
was a white supremacist and she founded
planned parenthood so explain that to me
or the locations of planned parenthood
yeah exactly exactly but that's why
you know that's not an indictment from
me personally on planned parenthood's
choice of locations the left has their
arguments for it i'm just pointing out
why would a white supremacist be upset
with that yeah why why would they be
like oh gee oh darn no they would
probably be in favor of those those
those clinics no in fact i think uh live
action called up a planned parenthood
and said um i'd like to specifically
target a donation to specifically target
uh for black women
and they and they said they said yeah um
yeah
send it on over and and
he's like he's like yeah that is
wokeness cranked up to 11. i'm sure
you've got some critical race theorists
like woke you know uh planned parenthood
woman nurse or whatever and she's like
that's so nice of you yeah no it's true
he asks over the phone i can't remember
if it was live action but i don't know
it might have been i don't remember but
i do remember this guy over the phone
like i i want to make a donation for
people to have abortions like
could it go like specifically to like
minority he's like dancing around it a
little bit but he basically says yeah
could you like make sure this donation
goes to to getting black babies aborted
and they're like yes of course
wow
because the way they twist it in their
head and i have to put the disclaimer
independent women's form is neutral on
abortion but i'm personally in pro-life
um and that's the thing about the right
is that we allow for dispersed opinion
on this if you there are almost no
pro-life democrats uh they just for
example tried to book a you know
democrats for life tried to book a meal
for during the march for life uh at a
restaurant i think bus boys and poets in
dc
their reservation was cancelled once
they found out that these were democrats
for life um but i am personally pro-life
but there's actually a lot of democrats
that are pro-life it's huge yeah but but
they're suppressed by the establishment
and then you can't fundraise especially
if you're a female democrat good luck
getting money and i would say they're
not particularly pro-life if they're
willing to just vote democrat knowing
they're voting against their own
interests exactly but not not to derail
the conversation speaking of truckers
they're doing the same thing but it's
the same old tired playbook i'm tired of
saying it i'm tired of hearing it but uh
to be honest it's getting to a point
where now it's uh it's comical it's like
oh you're doing that thing again
you're claiming the protesters are
racist exactly wow what year is it is it
20 2016
oh it's 2022. well and this is a new bit
there was a there was an incredibly
insightful article written in 2016 and i
can't remember who wrote it
unfortunately but their whole point was
after the election they realized that
they couldn't go around calling people
racist anymore and it wasn't that they
realized that you can't just call people
names they just understood that that
term had lost its meaning so they
started saying white supremacist after
that
and then they started saying white
supremacists all the time and now i
think they've moved on to they're really
playing with using like incitement of
violence as their new term threat to
democracy or threat to democracy yeah
but it's it's just the same way of
saying the same different way of saying
the same thing which is that you're
disobedient it's chicken little just
running around screaming the sky is
falling it's the boy who cried wolf i
gotta be honest i literally don't care
yeah someone could be marching around
protesting anything and they would be
like that person's racist and i'd like
huh
what else is on i don't care i don't
care it doesn't matter they've lost the
words lost
meaningless yeah yeah and i i'm speaking
of threat to democracy i just read a
really great piece about the actual
threat to democracy right now is the
soros-funded das who are literally
ignoring the will of the people by
choosing to pick and choose whatever
they feel like prosecuting these are
laws that have been passed by the
legislative branch there's a thing
called separation of powers that says
the executive branch is is supposed to
it's not optional you can't
the d.a in new york for example can just
unilaterally decide something these
aren't suggestions so that is the actual
threat to democracy and i'm really glad
to see people like my former boss john
solomon uh he's he's been able to do
some great reporting about this and
enforcing uh documents uh for example in
missouri the prosecutor uh who was
source funded in st louis um
people are starting to wake up thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 00 pm
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you